[Music]
supermarkets
it's hard to avoid these modern temples
of convenience and consumerism and like
the fictitious temples from adventure
stories they are filled pitfalls and
booby traps designed to make you spend
more than you planned as any good
treasure hunter will tell you you can
never let your guard down there's
nothing to fit here security but with a
little preparation a discipline you can
safely swing past every metaphorical
snake pit rolling Boulder and alien
spaceship let's pretend
[Music]
from the moment you walked through the
front door your senses are getting
played bright colorful flowers the smell
of fresh-baked bread soft comfortable
music all these things are designed to
put you in a relaxed suggestive state of
mind so that you'll take your time and
be more open-minded about what you came
to buy if you're like most people you
probably start in the produce section
and that's no accident stores have found
that when people stop their cart with
healthy things early on there are more
likely to reward themselves with junk
food later it may be tempting to grab
some of those pre chopped fruits and
vegetables but take a second to compare
the price by weight you could be paying
two to three hundred percent more to not
have to wield the knife yourself plus
they often have a shorter shelf life and
you're creating more packaging waste
that's why I chop my own vegetables five
days a week
oh and by the way that mist that makes
everything seem fresh and crisp it's
pretty much just there for show
constantly spraying water on produce can
increase the health risks of bacteria
and make certain fruits and veggies rot
faster it also makes some produce wait
just a bit more check out so make sure
you shake them out before you back them
as you walk the aisles remember to look
up and down not just side to side stores
put their most expensive items ilvl
hoping you won't notice the cheaper
alternatives above and below and yes
that applies to kids stuff too excuse me
would you like a free sample sure I
guess free samples are more about your
emotions than your taste buds they
create a feeling of personal obligation
like you're already in too deep to back
out so if you're gonna partake be
prepared to make a clean break and move
on you're just gonna walk away after
everything we've been super markets
don't just want you to buy expensive
stuff they want you to buy more stuff in
general take this so-called bargain
most people assume they have to purchase
all 10 to get some perceived discount
but if you read the fine print you'll
usually find that the unit price is the
same no matter how many you buy it's
also why shopping carts have been
getting bigger over the years Marketing
tests showed that shoppers spent up to
40% more with a double-sized cart those
super sized parts also make it difficult
to do a u-turn in a narrow aisle so
you're more likely to take the long way
round a longer path means more
temptations which is why stores will
periodically rearrange the merchandise
to keep even experienced shoppers
searching some people think that's why
essentials like milk and eggs are always
at the back of the store but store
managers insist on a more innocent
reason by law these items can't be
unrefrigerated for very long and since
the delivery trucks unload at the back
it makes sense to put the fridges there
I guess making shoppers watch the whole
store is just half
accident once you finally found
everything you need there's one more
trial to overcome that check stand this
is where stores traditionally keep
impulse purchases like candy and
magazines and gum because they know that
right now you're experiencing what
psychologists call decision fatigue we
get tired being sensible and weighing
costs and benefits
it weighs us down and it makes us more
open to suggestion so it's best to not
even look at that stuff don't shut your
eyes Marion don't look at it no matter
what happens these strategies have been
refined over decades to make shoppers
spend more than they have to and buy
more than they need unfortunately people
who buy more tend to consume more and
waste more it's kind of a lose lose lose
situation but shopping for groceries and
cooking at home is still cheaper and
healthier than eating out all the time
which is a major reason why Millennials
are having trouble saving money so by
all means go to the supermarket just be
prepared first off and most importantly
make a list even if you have to write it
on a napkin in the parking lot don't go
through those doors without it the fewer
choices you have to make in the store
means less fatigue and less temptation
if your store has them use smaller carts
to discourage overbuy although those
hand baskets may not be a good idea
studies found that the physical act of
lifting and carrying hand baskets made
shoppers feel like they deserved junk
food rewards the brains of funny thing
isn't it bring headphones and listen to
upbeat music this will keep you fast and
focused
and make sure you don't go grocery
shopping hungry that's just asking your
reptile brain to take the driver's seat
and if you still have trouble sticking
to the plan leave your credit cards at
home and bring only what you want to
spend in cash Julia and I have been
doing that for years and it keeps
temptation in check
remember these stores aren't evil
organizations getting away with highway
robbery
in fact as an industry supermarkets have
one of the lowest profit merchants in
the u.s. so they rely on these mind
games just to stay in black but you have
a right to defend yourself and the best
defense is understanding how your brain
works and that's our two cents
[Music]
you